hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreigner again and the
new update has just went live on April
1st it is the raving rabbids another
popular Ubisoft game they've now invaded
for honor and taken over the minions for
24 hours if you do happen to join the
game you will get a melee pack as a
reward I thought I believe it comes with
some steel and some scavenger crates
that's always some good stuff to see and
with that probably playing some Dominion
seeing as they took over the minions and
I try to hop into a breach game but I
was keen for 15 minutes and I don't want
to sit through that [ __ ] again because
apparently it breaches a dead game-mode
I don't get it yeah everything's
changing the jazz music the hero menu
the minions this thing is changing
there's everything is flying on the
screen back here I don't know what the
hell I'm seeing yeah I'd like to be if
you do enjoy a subscriber for new my
Twitter and discord will be in the
description if you guys want to follow
that and join those and with that let's
get started okay boy so I may have
figured this out I've been playing for
the past hour it's 12:55 but basically
been playing since this thing is
starting I've started the recording and
I've yet to find them in the game the
only thing that's worked is putting on a
breach game in a Custer any type of game
mode that has minions in a custom game
or if you happen to play a game mode
with matchmaking turned off so it's all
BOTS and I can tell when they come in
because the washing machines there and
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] stupid god the
cutscene makes this thing 12 I like 10
times worse yeah it's a mixture of
minions with the rabbits helmets but
it's also just rabbits in general so
this gameplay is gonna be on a custom
game that I made with just level 2 BOTS
and me and a breach game because I
literally cannot find a game with these
guys in it I don't know if it's like
that's how its intended or if it's like
every so often maybe you'll get the
Rabbids in the game because some of the
time they don't even show up and it's
kind of confusing so we're just gonna be
playing this just because I mean the
whole point isn't really to win this is
just kind of look at how stupid all this
is I set them to level two just beat the
bots level two just because I didn't
want them to be at level 3 and be super
hard or level ones that I'm killing them
all
but these guys look absolutely dumb I
love it
now the Rabbids have this little
notoriety for being really annoying so
if you hate them if you hated them
before you're gonna hate the next 24
hours because these guys do not shut up
every single noise I've heard so far
besides the regular sword clanging has
been this and on top of that anything
captured like like the RAM moving or
anything like that the announcer doesn't
make the you captured zone a or some
[ __ ] it's a rapid going wow why it's
like some weird stuff it's got our big
action these these rabbits are actually
really huge wait a minute do they turn
into chicken wait a minute what is it
our way hold on why is there chicken on
the floor hold on a second what is that
is that just there wait what the [ __ ]
hold on a second you got me all types of
confused why is there chicken on the
floor where's a shaman oh I'm stuck in a
corner
oh please don't kill me up please please
please please please please
valium break you please you know you
know you want to do it you know anyway
that's the whole dude
whoa that was close that was really
close yeah so there's these little
chicken things on the floor and I don't
know what they do cuz they're like they
disappear but then they just start
reappearing I don't know if like that's
them respawn like that's them dying or
so oh oh wait that is okay so every time
they die when their player model goes
away they turn into chicken what this
updates stupid I have few people I've
seen in my discord asking me about this
because some of them don't have time to
play at the moment since it is pretty
late at night it's fruit so from what
I've discovered from the matches I've
completed
there isn't anything customizable I
doubt I knew that I had a feeling that
this wasn't that really wasn't gonna be
a thing so far from my games I haven't
gotten anything in terms of masks
outfits or effects or something like
that so just keep that in mind I'm
pretty sure this event is just strictly
for fun and that all we're really doing
is just changing up the mid there so
much shaking on the floor dude oh my god
Peter never Peter better never watched
this video then when at Pete is having a
heart attack right now they're gonna
they're gonna sue Ubisoft for this 1000%
yeah there shouldn't really be anything
customisable I think this is just all
for fun change in the minions for a bit
and remember this is only for 24 hours
this is technically considered a new
event and this is only for 24 hours so
if you do have the time you get Amalia
pack for playing or for at least logging
on so and I've experienced at least one
of these games it's pretty funny to look
at now what's got me curious which I'll
get to is the commander are the
commander especially the the like the AI
boss like the mini boss you can call it
within this is he gonna be a mint is he
gonna be like a like a rabbit to like
what's happening with that I know
they're not I know he's not considered a
minion but like I don't even know really
what's a call I know the captain's I
believe aren't changed which kind of
said so I'm pretty sure they're not
gonna be changed as well but we'll see
you later when we get to the next part
of the map
now that I think about it we've had a
lot of events in the past right we've
had a lot of events in this game that
have changed the minions a tremendous
amount specially the music I think for
Honor's should really add some type of
menu system to where the hero screen the
main menu all that stuff and needs to be
changed to like you can change it so if
I'm feeling like in a good mood I can
maybe turn on the Rabbids music just for
some fun or from enlight you know if i
want to get like real dark i could turn
on the recent event that we just had the
black prior one cuz that's got the red
spooky stuff i feel like since we've
gone through just about three almost
three years yeah I think we're like two
and a half at the moment in terms of
events I feel like we should have the
ability to you know change the minions I
change the minions change the menu just
to give it that little spice I know that
it's a not a permanent mode and I
understand that and there's probably no
way to calculate that we have it
although I'm pretty sure you could
basically have it so that you know at
least for this you know you if you've
collected the mail a pack that counts as
you going into the event or if you've
gotten some type of piece of gear from
the event that counts as you playing it
so then you have access to it so it's
not like people that just recently
joined can get access to the Halloween
event because they have employed you
know the first one cuz they haven't
played it but I feel like it'll be
really interesting just you know just a
little switch up this game's not
realistic at all so I mean I really
don't see I really don't see a like a
problem with doing it at all
so one thing I didn't take into account
is the fact that I joined the defenders
team and since they're bots I could
easily beat them so like for the past
two minutes I've actually kind of let
them get to the next area cuz I want to
see the rest of it I want to see if the
you know the commander the the mini-boss
whatever you want to call him the
warrior whatever has the change as well
I completely forgot about that I
probably should have picked attackers
all right well oh right his name's the
Guardian I'm stupid all right well I can
confirm that the Guardians not changed
either which probably means the
commander's not changed that's kind of
sad but you know I'll take the minions I
think that's still pretty nice I also
just realized that they're not using
weapons I think one of them I think
they're using those toilet scrubber
things I forgot what they're called
they're not plungers but it's like
discovered toilets with I just noticed
that they're using that what the actual
hell are their [ __ ] well they have the
samurai stuff so that so from what well
what I've seen though from pictures on
reddit is that they're that the Rabbids
actually do have like they can use
plungers so I think it just depends on
the faction cuz I guess for the samurai
they have the toilets covers everything
else is completely fine
these guys just use discovers if I go to
all right those guys are also samurai or
just I don't know because I remember
seeing a picture of them using plungers
but that could just been like concept
art or like some art or whatever well I
hope everybody's hungry because we have
an endless supply of food in the middle
of the map here and even more back here
oh my goodness thank God man you have no
idea how long I waited up on that bridge
that I was at before I died just to see
this thing oh my lord the commander has
a bunny outfit this is definitely gonna
be a screen shot worthy thumbnail I
meant so happy about this all right that
that just exceeded all my expectations
that they can't the company know the
captain didn't have it nobody else had
it but the commander does and I think
that's probably the best part about
playing breach this is amazing I got to
see this commander in action bro did the
commander always speak like that like I
don't remember the commander always
speaking like English has he always done
that I I don't know if it's just cuz I
don't play breech anymore I'm stupid or
something I remember the commander
speaking this much I know he would speak
but I don't know that's just weird
that's just me though maybe I'm just
really stupid oh [ __ ] the whole oh [ __ ]
eat
rarrr [ __ ] hold on
rawr yeah no get out of here
hit yourself Oh hate to see it well bye
that's one oh you [ __ ] prick Oh eat
sharp and bladed oh you scumbag
that's two down yeah not on bud
bop easy Perry stop it oh okay well yeah
just gave that one away
easy win you know they were totally top
tier players definitely not BOTS
[Music]
absolutely amazing event I probably
would have got higher in the in the
leaderboard here with the team if I
wasn't letting the enemy team go just so
I could see the commander which i think
was well worth the wait
hey guys it's gonna be the end of the
video say hope you guys did enjoy if you
guys do want to check out this event
game-mode it's gonna be going live all
throughout April 1st it started around
April 1st at midnight and it's gonna end
at on April 2nd at midnight see if
exactly 24 hours to hop on and get the
mail I pack experience this stuff the
new they did jazz music you know all the
stuff in the background the hero menu
everything's been changing and if you
hate the Rabbids before you're
definitely gonna hate them again and I
would probably advise you to hold off on
400 for the next 24 hours if you don't
like that you have let me know your
thoughts on the new event here for
that's gonna be here for 24 hours I
think this is actually really fun I
cannot wait to keep playing this more it
is around like 2:00 in the morning so
I'm definitely gonna go get some sleep I
got a couple exams then in the morning
after so I probably shouldn't be
recording this video but you know I got
to put out that content for you guys
yeah I like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being balanced changes here or updates
patch notes and leaks if you want to be
kept up today with everything happening
within the world of for honor that we
stay subscribe to the channel my two
most recent videos are gonna be popping
up on screen if you guys want to check
those out with that have fun enjoy the
event and peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]